the choice was
simple in favor Contra or against Contra
in the end the message was clear just as
the majority of Chileans had rejected a
draft Constitution last year seen as too
far left this time they voted against
one that was widely viewed as even more
right-wing than their current Charter
written under Chile's former P
dictatorship it's better to stay with
the dis ing constitution of P reformed
by two Progressive presidents than to
have this totally right-wing version
that borders on
fascism but some would have preferred
this last offer to put the matter to
rest I think it's gone long enough so 3
years ago Chileans voted overwhelmingly
to draft a new constitution am made
widespread demands for constitutional
guarantees of better Education Health
pensions and women's rights but clearly
they feel let
down this represents the radicalization
of everything that was criticized about
the Constitution that we currently
have the biggest irony is that after not
one but two tries Chileans will be left
with their dictatorship era Charter for
the foreseeable
future I think the tragedy of all this
is the failure of our political class
they were given two chances to address
our problems and they haven't been up to
the challenge
and perhaps that's why many feel that
there have been no winners here except
perhaps those who've always refused to
put the dictatorships last Legacy to
rest Lucia Newman Al jazer Santiago